it's the OL things comedy podcast studio
welcomes my kyung-chul batch cough as
mike young stories that need to be told
podcast we are in phoenix arizona for
all things comedy comedy festival I'm
sitting here with two old friends
they're not old because of their age
we've just known each other a long long
time Joel bash cough Matt komen owners
operators general managers bartender
whatever they done it all from the
bottom up and I've wanted to talk to you
guys for a long time because ironically
no one's put you on their podcast yet
you know everything about comedy Joel
I've known you probably 16 years right
maybe long I mean listening here 16 17
years when I started comedy absolutely I
mean Matt Coleman I've known you five
seven nine what do you think 11 yeah
comas got a million voices dying to be a
comedian but is not so he's just looking
forward to karaoke tomorrow but these
guys have run thank you very much for
the alcohol they've run the improv chain
the copper blues chain Joel what else
will demand of live stand-up live and do
you think it's ironic that now there's
like TV shows about stand-ups and I know
you've probably been hearing about these
type of shows wanting to get on the air
for like 20 years people have probably
been talking about like you got to do
the dark side of comedy you got to do a
show about how many times have you heard
that and then finally now there's a show
on Showtime I'm dying up here are you
surprised that the show [ __ ] took this
long like this to get on the air after
what you've seen and gone through and
looked at and what do you think kommen
you look ready to talk I was really I
know but I know I saw Joel fall asleep I
was waiting to hear Joel and then I
could know by backup what he's seeing I
was it was the reverse it's like he kept
leaning in yeah every time he kept
leaning in I was like I hate well I'm
alright Joel you take the question take
the question are you surprised it took
this long and is
there are a very sided comedy the
problem is egos I think it's been an ego
play I think that with having so many
different chains out there especially
the two silverback gorillas that a
silverback was for Katie Meyers ladies
and gentlemen silverback gorilla that
between the improv and the Comedy Store
I think that people didn't know what
direction to go to because people are
claiming that they helped start right so
ego got in the way is a telling story
which I yeah where did really Andy
Kaufman start did he start at the end
prompted he started at The Comedy Store
I think at the end of the day you got to
look at the both places they have
totally improv and Comedy Store have
totally different personalities you know
I mean I believe you know to me you go
to the comedy store it's a different
it's a different vibe it's a darker vibe
it's a it's a more artist not artist
friendly but it's more of a creative
space you know I mean there's people
having sex in a dark corner on a third
floor there's a third there's police
around at all times
sort of darker vibe than the improv I
would say it also changed over the years
because back in the day when I was
booking the improv the cool part about
it was it was a hank because you could
go hang with all the comics that you
loved and saw on TV there was no social
media in the Comedy Store all the comics
were in the back of the kitchen so if
you went to the comedy store you never
actually got to see the comics you were
there and then The Improv that was so
cool you could be at the bar with all
the biggest names work and you know that
weekend and now I think what happened
was the Comedy Store got the bar outside
and it was people driving by could see
and then it became the hang it became
the cool place to be and the Improv I
think lost some of that I wonder what
made the change in the Comedy Store over
the last six seven years to get it
really back booming it like it like it
is again you think it's a lineup
I mean it's called owners I think what
do you think I think as in for the
Comedy Store from what I heard us being
improv guys there's two ways to look at
it there's a way to look at it as we're
owners and operators and
where I wouldn't say where improv guys
is it's a it's a brand that we work with
yeah as a fan I would probably say I'm a
Comedy Store fan yeah can I and I think
with that is I think that they had a
Booker you have a lot of personalities
between you know mitzi getting older and
having multiple sons and a daughter that
are always to me constantly going back
and forth on what direction the store
should go into they got the right book
or which started out at an improv at the
Tempe improv who's booking it now and
bringing in the the faces that always
wanted to go there but didn't want to
have to deal with the drama but for me
for me being a fan like as I said
there's two hats I wear on a financial
side yeah I am an improv we own improv
so we actually started our own brand
which is stand-up live doing that great
I've played a few of them which is great
but I got to tell you if I was a comic
and I wanted to feel the culture I feel
right now the store is just more
inviting and again not taking anything
from The Improv I love The Improv and I
I want to see it succeed and be part of
something bigger but I think that
culture wise there's a lot there's a
it's a lot happening yeah it almost
feels like The Improv was MySpace and
Friendster and then Comedy Store became
like Twitter and snapchat and Instagram
and it just it developed that and I
think from the bar and the lineups and
Rogen's and Joey and the surprise
Poppins people who are popping that's
what I used to get but I think the
comedy store again these these comics
were kind of hidden and they didn't see
they had the original room they had the
main room they had a belly room but it
wasn't as controlled nobody really knew
what was gonna expect up there and then
I was social right you're getting those
pop-ups you're building a buzz from the
Comedy Store and you're seeing Wow and
it's also on Sunset Boulevard so I think
that there's also that mystique being up
there on Sunset like The Laugh factories
like that when you drive by the laughs
after you would just see the line but
there's nowhere to hang inside in the
Laugh Factory right it's now the Comedy
Store and you got all that but you know
that's what I loved about the Improv
back in the day was being able to sit at
the bar and you're just hanging out
having drinks with Jeff Ross Gaffigan
you know and louis c.k and they're just
all hanging in there waiting to go on
their cell we're not when I came out for
the first time I was I started at the
Miami improv
20 years ago never been out to LA always
was obsessed that's where I wanted to be
it was a to me it was a stepping stone
and a and a way into the industry going
out to LA for the first time meeting
Budd Friedman walking in seeing David
Spade up on the stage looking at the
mystique I was you know you get blown
away it's almost like drinking it's
drinking that kool-aid and then becoming
friends with guys like you that are
comics and just being blown away of wow
that's what you do on a daily basis it
for me and never gets old so you were
already at the Miami improv before you
ever made it to LA like I never been
tell never been to LA one of the first
people that I met when I went to LA was
Mac Holman and he worked at the improv
booking office and we can go into the
story of how I asked what he was doing
that evening and he said oh I got a I
got a party in the hills very busy which
which I kind of felt douchey and we
allowed to curse felt like a dick yeah
and biggest sounds like people you hang
out in me and Matt pulled Mac home and
pulled I got a party in the hills and
like this you didn't let Julie go hold
on in my party I don't like that that's
a party in the hills it was just me and
three dudes going out to a bar drinking
you know but at least he could tell
anybody
Joel's gotta be cool he's coming from
Miami
washing money in Miami so he was taken
to an edgy party in LA my mentor was
washing the money I was actually
visually Y watching it and learning how
to do it in the future did you even have
a love of stand-up when you were working
the Miami improv is a straight business
for you did you for me nothing to do
with business I guess I got paid nothing
peanuts so to me it was I was paid by
experience and but one of the first
comics I have ever worked with was angel
Salazar Oh check it out and I was like
oh my god this guy was teaching from
Scarface I was like this is incredible
so you fell in love with the game fell
in love and then all
sudden Bobby sláinte and comes in and a
mic dude he played Joey Bishop in the
rat pack I was like yeah and then the
greatest by far at that time rest in
peace
Richard Janney comes in and mom walking
I walk in he's in the mirror looking at
touching his hair going crazy and I'm
just like I will never ever ever walk
away from this business ever see that
that's what I like about you Joel you
love the business love it you both love
the business I used to do stand-up
I believe when I've done nine voices
since we said that great expressions
could not write a joke yeah I absolutely
believe it's like some of the biggest
names in I wanna brag but I was in an
improv troupe in college listen Adam the
Booker at The Comedy Store who used to
work for you here in Tempe yeah
he's he didn't work for me I don't want
to like a lot one thing I want to keep
an eye on okay he worked at the improv
before we took it over got it okay I
don't know that's what I knew that's
where I knew him from but I'm saying he
was one of the only people that I knew
that didn't seem like he wanted to be a
comedian like all of a sudden you'll
know someone 12 years from working
around the country and you won't even
think that like the waitress or the host
or that they want to be a comedian then
all of a sudden boom they moved to LA
I'm like you do comedy
you mean like everybody in the mix or
everybody wants not not to brag about
the improper thing about like Bette
Midler and some of the biggest names and
some of the biggest names that are
agents and managers work the door at the
improv again this is more improv Astoria
because ya know I love it and it's it's
amazing where you can go and I'm in my
how I felt even though I I had the
perfect opportunity and I was training
out in uh in Miami I always wanted to be
out in LA this is just it's contagious
you're just like you're you don't feel
like you're part of the industry when
you're across the country well that's
interesting because you are in the
industry you own a multiple improv and
yeah you are you gonna move to LA or do
you have a place there yet can I stay
what's going on of it you know you got a
spot I went out for six months Mac home
and we can get to that story how I I
ended up renting an apartment but since
I didn't know anyone I stayed with him
and his fiancee at the time and just I
didn't take out the trash one time he's
like love you
go you gotta go and then say who I want
reduced him who I interested I am I
introduced him they said I said hey Joel
who's that girl working over here over
there he said don't worry about her I'm
firing her tomorrow
so that's his lobbying you know Robin
Robin Robin that's your wife yeah
congratulations lot of a woman he
married up no he married like honey not
up like nothing like five store even
Katie settled Meyers from Antigua malos
Panama hopper blues drinks Bud Light an
Tito's that high yes oh man I'm on there
so I must really think you own it I mean
look we went to the Bahamas we worked it
out we went on a mancation we went on a
mancation on the medication did you
third wheel the medication or he did you
to me John and then I got caught
I got caught up in the room watching a
lifetime special which I'm happy Ritter
just get away you know and dump
downstairs gamblin hanging out having
some cocktails I'm like Joel I call them
up there and then I said Joe come on man
let's go down let's go Gambon he goes
hold on a second I'll be right down I'm
just finishing up a John Ritter movie on
lifetime that's why I love you I love
you bro he ended up they went upstairs
we watched coach Carter to follow which
was I think we should all take a sip of
our Bud Light go ahead go out on drink
beer but I appreciate I love Bud Light
but when he does but when he does he
drinks Bud Light and if you know what I
don't row straight tequila and the
greatest thing about Bud Light is
drinking it at cityscape I wonder if Bud
Lights a sponsor me I've never heard
anyone talk to me but like my life
shout-out to Bud Light will take another
seven Wow
listen first of all that wasn't the
number yeah second of all we are in city
place right now do you realize like we
are in we're in downtown city scape any
places in Palm Beach here in Phoenix not
City place on my mind it's a little
problematic so we're in city scape right
now you realize that's where you are
will you stop promoting the real estate
bro we don't own comedy Mike Young
anyone's listening right now yeah get on
down Phoenix downtown in all things
comedy there's gonna be if there's a
festival it's happening
leave work hard or she'll get on that
Phoenix Jill Jill is just gazing off
about to start a promotional spot listen
we've known each other a long time I
don't know why let me say so mocking
cityscape right no no it's a great area
by the way have a fountain in the front
of our club because of you guys this
whole area started to boom when when you
first came in here
nobody wanted weird the revitalization
of downtown Phoenix and comedy clubs
they like comedy clubs cuz their
destination sites right so yeah people
are driving from 20 30 40 minutes away
so what was cool is we really were one
of the first tenants down here oh it was
obvious its KITT Matt can you tell him
about the Tom Cruise Ron Matt can run
better than 2011 okay I'm in Phoenix
open in the first weekend first weekend
very emotional by the way you know when
I'm coming to club like no [ __ ] like you
cry and it's just it is a lot to handle
well I go to pick up Joe coins the first
night we open and I text my wife like
you know what this has been crazy been
traveling a lot you know day big day
everything's great first big investment
and I verify hit Send and I sent it
right to Jo koy oh right to home so I
pick him up at the end of the night it's
downtown Phoenix and you know it's like
3:00 in the morning I gotta get home the
next morning and I pull the Tom Cruise
like running through downtown Phoenix
down fright from the club like half a
mile away to the hotel and it was like
3:00 in the morning the sunset was
coming up I wished like there was like
bed level music behind me yeah I don't
know you could play it it was it was it
was it was my moment but open and open
in the club it's a it is a crazy
experience and but it is really cool
because you forget about it and with all
the [ __ ] that you do during the week
and for comedy general what's cool is
when you finally go to show and I need
to go out more but when I do when I go
see Carmen I go that's why I do it but
it's it's really tough to remember that
sometimes and you can't lose sight of
that because it is such an amazing
experience to see and I like actually
like to watch the crowd as opposed to
comics sometimes too and when you get
that electric room it's when there's
nothing better and when you have a
headliner about to go up
and the MC introduces them or her and
the crowd the stimulation to this day I
still get chills okay okay it's so let
me ask you this
leaning right into it I'm leaning so
there's there's monsters out there
headliners big names now as an owner and
as a businessman you got to make money
you got to make you got to pay rent you
got to do your thing so is it a
difficult thing for you sometimes to
have to maybe follow a trend because
somebody's popular and you have to put
them on and they're not a great comedian
or a great act or the other we're not
gonna say anything it's gotta weigh
heavy on your head because you're
battling yourself well here's a
difference when it's all subjective
right comedy on someone right and I'm
not even time not even talk about just
comedians I'm saying you might there
might be some like you know what you're
basically saying goofball [ __ ] the time
it's huge but it's very yeah fill the
seat but they're fans love it so to us
it may seem terrible and it may seem
crazy but you're still gonna get
whoever's buying a ticket they'll love
it you and I might look at each other
and go what the [ __ ] was that that's a
good point but so yeah so because
comedies become so niche right and
commonly so specific now like it used to
be the brand right you would go out you
would buy that night out a comedy
experiment it would be the biggest
comics and you just really wouldn't care
who's there nowadays you're you're
buying that comic that you love that you
don't want to miss yeah so these these
youtubers or these other you know shows
you're talking about and you know we we
know exactly what they are those YouTube
fans those 15 year olds or semitones
when you do a 13 Plus show we did a show
one time around the sangs they're
walking away going like the Beatles yeah
man it was like one direction they go
man like they literally think that was
their woman that was amazing the weather
just till I get her on I don't want to
interrupt but he went in one direction
and you notice I went Beatle no that's
what they said by the kids it was like a
whole different like I will walk right
on the spot same age range - it's weird
but with that being said with that being
said it's not being able to at this
point and I think with podcasts and I
think with like
with groups like all things comedy and
that's not a plug passivity all things
comedy witty toes at cityscape that
would be a plug what I'm saying is and
it's not that I'm getting paid is the
fact that at this point you can't I mean
if you guys go ahead I'm right here go
huh
the problem is you can't book funny
right now all the time because funny
doesn't pay the bills and as a club
owner that has passion that really wants
to build the experience of a night that
we should be able to book people that
aren't the names that are just funny
they come out they have great meal they
have great drinks but more important you
have a great show that takes them away
from that whatever is going on in their
lives for that hour and a half that
takes them to another place yeah
unfortunately people want to see some of
these names that you're like wow we
really have to jump through hoops and
and fight the fight and we don't want to
get into the whole agency and putting
out offers and the way we get treated on
the comedy club side when there's prop
there's thousands of comics out there
that you know just would work the road
for 52 weeks yeah and and that are so
funny that I feel sometimes that these
fans are robbed because they don't know
yeah like like I mean again it's it's
very hard for me to just throw out any
to just throw out a name but there's
just names out there in comics which you
can throw out that you know might not
sell a ticket but I swear to God are
funnier than some of the biggest names I
mean there is all their legs me
gentlemen at cityscape by Tim Tino's I'm
five movies in I can't get a headlining
gig who denied the call you said myself
tickets I said so thanks the problem has
anyone heard of me
and that's what you are doing what's
crazy how did you get a podcast if you
don't believe is this no man I gotta
call my agent seriously I gotta fight
eh that's what's incredible you are to
me one of the funniest I appreciate that
and but you still on the fence you do
spend a lot of time doing movies writing
directing producing on the road so
you're not helping yourself on the
comedy club side brand and we were gonna
I did want to talk to you offline about
this let's talk it up brokers I need to
be headlining like a [ __ ] but
you're the only one I could lend like a
mother wait are you talking bass
listening I can name five of your best
friends that worked the road every week
yeah totally you don't know you take off
you go do your movies you write you
direct and then you call up in like hey
man I want a headline know knows that
your song I have not bothered you know
but not know but not in it in a negative
way but the fact is is you're you're
doing something else that's behind the
scenes yeah it's like you're walking
behind this effort and repeating going
hi I'm Mike Young yeah what you want to
do right I mean ultimately you're
spending the time on what you want to do
a lot of these guys I mean I can't know
the weird thing is I love comedy as much
as I love directing I love writing as
much as I love stand-up I don't have a
favorite thing distracting isn't in the
front totally it's I get it high and
that I get it that's like Bert and
Sebastian and all your boys with all
comedy 24/7 you're making movies which
is pretty which is pretty incredible
yeah you can't dismiss what you're doing
it's that not being on the road like
like if I said to told in that work
that's it stand-up work and that's it
living in front of the in living in
front of the camera on the road 40 weeks
a year you're you're you're a thousand
percent correct and when I when I did my
first movie I said to myself every night
I'm gonna give you be on stage every day
I'm gonna work yeah I'll be on set I was
so exhausted I did not get on stage one
time in four months and that's what I
realized okay these are two different
things and there is no way I'm gonna be
a big-time comedian unless I go back to
dedicating and being in front of the
camera
yeah being in front of the camera like
put myself in my freakin movie or you
can be a very director if you don't
concentrate on that too so it's like if
you split the time then it's like you
know right and it becomes what do you
love the most and it's again it's that
straight line like I was in Hollywood
for thirteen years and I did no exact on
me growing up like watching def Comedy
Jam and like I knew I wanted to work in
comedy but I did a lot of lateral moves
I didn't know what that endgame was my
buddy who was an agent he went to the
agency when I see him now he's a partner
there 17 years because you know he knew
that straight line and I'm still kind of
the same thing doing that lateral move
and then you ultimately find a place but
you waste a lot of time on some level
figure out what you don't want to do but
within your case - it's like okay if you
wanted to be a stand-up maybe it's right
finding that that vehicle and the movie
side things gonna help you sell tickets
because look at the end of the day great
plot it's myself in it's all about
selling tickets yeah I mean like you
know with with anything at the box
office whether it's a movie it's all
about selling tickets you know but I do
believe I do believe where comedies
going and with podcasts it is helping
yeah I'll take it to where if you're not
on a sitcom because at the end of a day
- Maddie and I talk about it all time
because I watch all these sitcoms and I
watch all the reality shows from
America's Got Talent
we won't talk about any of the bookings
that I made Maddie uh send offers for
but actually sometimes I'm work those
even the sitcoms don't help but the
podcast do yeah and it's a voice so yeah
sometimes it's not just a visual thing
it's look at like Rogen I mean yeah of
course you have small space monster but
look at his podcast so it gets a girl
like I mean Joe Rogan first person to
bring me to the improv to your to your
spot years or years ago 15 years ago Joe
had me oh who is a monster then as a
comic but it was like he was from
Newsradio
but it was we were he was building I was
watching him build it was incredible now
and he's so cool to watch at that moment
I remember he tried to shoot a special I
think it was was it here or Orca it was
attempted it was actually working in
Tempe and that audio messed up I don't
know if you remember that but the audio
on the kiss first what was going to be
his special and
everybody went craters were flying in a
the worst [ __ ] audios [ __ ] up on a
special and I'll never forget that but
then I don't know if you saw recently if
you went onto Netflix Rogan live for
some weird reason it was like from that
moment it was like from like the
recording was from like then and I was
on his poster the poster on Netflix is
Joe Rogan and me not my name just me
next to him so somebody either like
awesomely photoshopped me into richest
man flicks I have no idea literally it's
a mystery yeah I don't know how I don't
know where it came from
I got it about I took a picture on my
phone I don't know I thought maybe like
someone at Netflix cuz my movie was on
was like trying to pull a smooth move
and like just put me on but anyway
Rogan took me to the improv you were the
first you guys were the first people to
book the young American comedy tour
which was insane I mean insane thank you
just insane just another dude get a job
and in Tempe just trying to make sure
that's happened or CH and a Tempe at the
time I was it was before Matty and I
even came to Arizona and we even built
stand-up live which turned into us
buying the Tempe improv I remember I was
working at the improv booking office I
was working I I was a an owner investor
an operator in South Florida but I was
wanting to learn the business so bad
that I was taking red eyes and flying
across the country to work in the improv
booking office and I'll never forget
Danmark rest in peace to rest in peace I
mean I would pour beer but I'm not gonna
waste it ya know I didn't love Dan but
look not everyone that dodge you have to
love I mean that's it that's not gonna
do that alright so all of a sudden I
mean all of a sudden young Americans
come in and sell out every show and I
mean not like so out like as an give
away every show to where it looks like I
said what do you think it wasn't like it
was like I know what it was
let me just Pat myself on the back this
was pre social media this was no social
media was this 10 years ago 2006 nine
years a YouTube no social media no no
followers
now it was was this I heard this is how
my brain was working back that I
somebody who was like the kings of
comedy with all those big name Bernie
Mac they made 16 million dollars
somebody kept saying like they made
millions on the road so one night I'm on
the patio of the Comedy Store I swear to
God and I have an eye look out and like
we just i see me it's me I'm talking to
Sebastian
I see Bret Ernst I see Tony rock
crushers hammered shirtless in a corner
and I have one and I have this epiphany
and I go wait a minute if they made 16
million I'm like we gotta be worth at
least like 2 million like we're not not
funny well I'll bet you I'm in the
millions out I mean like were worth no
LeGrande no no cuz I thought to myself
we're like really really really funny
but really unknown but like not way less
funny we're not 16 million less funny
that was remind so I was like I'm gonna
make up a tour and I [ __ ] went home
and I just made up the young American
comedy to it everyone's like even
they're like madly butch Bradley was on
it Tony rock was on it Bobby Lee was on
it you kept reaching him out I switched
them on the brand you're selling the
brand was a moment so I went it was a
great moment thank you it was thank you
for booking us and making it Cano but
then all of a sudden in the improv which
they tend to do hopped on the bandwagon
I end up saying well they killed it in
they killed it in Phoenix and Tempe I
was like let's bring him into the my
club in South Florida yeah I ended up
booking it there you guys had great
relationships with all the radio
stations and we knocked it out of the
park
I mean it was it was the most fun thing
ever and it should have gone on for five
years but when I tell you that I did it
my son my own and had no gate again oh I
want to write a movie no no it wasn't
anything about that I had a sit-down I'm
just gonna be real with you they brought
me into the headquarters improv at
levity we're living ashore whatever
whatever it was at that time I'm power
entertainment no no it was after that I
was after it was at Le gee
okay this is my first gangster sit down
so I got set
I got sat down at levity or whatever
they were called then same office so I
think same Q's Park Park Hughes Parkway
whatever it is I go in Hartman sitting
there Judy there's like a bunch of
people around the table and Hartman
gives me like this and they had booked
just like 21 shows already where it was
going great but all of a sudden I was
noticing like they were like it was like
tapering off a little bit so I was like
what is going on like why are we not
getting bigger why are the doors closing
when that we should be opening and
Hartman was like do you own the young
American comedy tour I was like yeah I
own it I pay to re-up it I [ __ ] spent
thousands on photo you know doing photo
shoots and all kinds of crazy [ __ ] and
he's like okay and he was like you know
would you want a partner would you think
about partnering I was like yeah oh I
didn't even know what that meant
I just putting this out that I know of
Matt chrome and sneaking right now no no
I literally did not know what he meant
when he said that it was like some
subtle [ __ ] I was not a businessman per
se I really did not I should have a
lawyer with me and I must have probably
said like I'm not gonna sing I must have
said something like I'm not looking for
partners or some weird [ __ ] like that
and then yeah before I knew it we were
like we had to go find like a little
tiny like 500 seat theaters to go do cuz
the Improv like stop booking us and I
was paying this is this is I was flying
by the seat of my pants for real so like
you I didn't know anything about offers
you gave me offers I just accepted that
they were bad I don't know I just looked
at the money and I was like well I'll
just pay myself this and then split the
rest with the guys what I realized later
was I was overpaying my guys because
when Christ and like and even Brett when
they started headlining on their own uh
they were making like 300 less on their
own then with the tour so I basically I
learned a lot by the way
well there was enough anybody wants to
hire me as a tour manager creative
whatever I'll [ __ ] run your well no
there was another thing too I didn't
know what was happening by going into me
why are we not the biggest tour on
planet Earth well the other thing too is
that do you know anything I I definitely
know something the fact that you went
there and I know more the opportunity
they also had the opportunity to
cherry-pick and say okay we could sign
and make more money individually with
Sebastian or with a Bert Kreischer and
they just looked at your rock you
basically brought them a roster so
basically they said nine million dollars
I would probably say a little more
I brought the maracas great talent scout
yeah and that's all why should I picked
a team movies town Scout Don done my
production company and I could pick a
softball team by the way they were all
on my softball team our team was doing
reality show you should have sold that
as a reality show people Steve Byrne was
on the tour it was burned Christ sure
Bobby Sebastian it got so fun
cherry-pick got so much fun that Rogen
came back Joe Rogan came to me he said
dude I'll do it Russell Peters is like
y'all bro he was already huge he's like
what are you doing I want to do it I'm
like I don't even know how to talk to
you about your contract like dick don't
you do stadiums like where are we going
it'll be the Russell Peters presents the
young about the comedy to it and I'm
going oh it's my fault well I could have
you can re-engage Tony Roxton and then I
would have Matthew all the work and Katy
you know it would have been perfect I
mean it was just it was a it was a great
moment in time and we had so much fun
and I can just tell you one fun story
that kicked off is well we we had to do
photo shoots because like we had no
picture I remember your headshots so we
we had headshots
but I was in a basketball league you
know this with DiCaprio and Tobey
Maguire in Everett so I cried by the way
he is not name dropping because as a fan
of actors and I am that guy he did hang
out with those guys like those are his
bros like the Caprio wire they're my boy
and then Mike Young and then Mike Jones
no one knows what they'll talk yeah yeah
we talked beat the club on Saturday
night bro snoops snoops DJ oh okay we're
here you want to have some real
Hollywood fun Joel start booking the
young American life on a planet let's
bring it back
let's do it okay Tony Rock is in me
Brett's in 104 expensive it's getting
very excited no no I'll cut everyone's
money down I don't have a car in I told
him that he should look for the younger
comics and redo it and do a part two you
know what I've done that job but you
know what's so interesting it is not
easy to find good young because
everybody at that time even though we
were younger they were still banging
like everyone was banging so I wouldn't
want to like let the brand suffer but if
you if you said to me yo there's some
young comics that can destroy rooms with
different styles cuz that was what it
was was I was blue-collar butch was
Irish crazy Tony was smooth Sebastian
was Italian
we had like you know everybody had a
difference science was brighter an
spreaders was art he was an
argumentative was he doing the roller
skating bit great
Dylan the roller skating bit crushing it
everywhere that chair was real Hollywood
it was insane you know the funniest [ __ ]
was is that baby see I became a
babysitter for comedian like getting
them to radio was very difficult no
trust us we know and you know so try
getting four dudes to radio and I
remember Paul was like this is funny
thing and uh I just remember getting a
call that you know like Paul loved you
like Paul and Ron Paul loved Mike loved
Brett yeah we and then all of a sudden
goes you know if it's alright if you
don't bring Sebastian back totally yeah
it goes
don't bring pieces Sebastian sat in the
corner he's like look man my legs and
now he bags he's like yeah you know
spatulas coming in concert and like
that's the iron use that's it so that's
what's so great because Sebastian sat
back but if you're in a room with Brad
it's on it's an I grew up with Brad like
I mean it's it's a thing he's never
changed correct
no yes has been he has his adidas shell
tops on and he's ready to rumble at all
times his headshot was him in a sweat
it's still the same headshot right this
is 21 years old dude a sweat suit sweat
suit you could totally pull off as well
I have multiple clearly yeah I look like
a little person
like juicy on your butt sweat suit
thanks Matt it was a company it was a
compliment you're good at with a hoodie
though Matt looks good with a hoodie on
I like focus it's like a horse with
blinders were you from Matt I grew up in
st. Louis were you were you doing open
mics in st. Louis no I just I literally
had such a fascination with comedy
growing up watching def Comedy Jam and
any evening at The Improv and like I
that's what I wanted more than anything
was to be a comic that's all I'm going
to school at Indiana and you know tried
stand-up I was in the up all night
Gilbert Godfried Rhonda Shear the USA
like like talent competition this is so
terrible my buddy convinced me to wear a
shirt that said I'm shy and really big
letters but says but I got a really big
dick and like I thought that was like
okay like I was like hey judge look at
this and I did impressions and it was
terrible and how long after did you know
you were not going to go into comedy but
you'd be on the business side how long
how long was a straight I did the the
improv troupe in college and we played
like every Friday night to pack the
rooms I was terrible at it couldn't find
the game whatever the [ __ ] they call it
I was like I wasn't good at air I would
just get drunk and like go and just you
know have fun and I moved into the
classic cliché me and a buddy moved to
LA drove the car out and everything and
then I worked for HBO with the us comedy
Arts Festival and that's when it kind of
like transition of like okay I'm going
into business yeah like I'm not you see
like I found like a tape of Tina Fey or
something like that you know you're a
rumbling through literally we found Tina
Fey and Seth Meyers
Seth was doing a show called pickups and
hiccups it was on VHS tapes I don't want
to date myself do I Tina Fey was doing
Dratch and Fey out of second city in
Chicago and at the time what we're
getting VHS tapes like there's no
MySpace there's like no you can't send a
link yeah but that was it man and I was
a talent scout basic and I was out five
seven nights a week at the clubs in LA
and then when I started booking Melrose
I was in my mid-20s I was eating and
drinking for free and I just hung out
there Monday through you know Saturday
I'd good home at 107 I'd wake I have my
VHS you know 24 episode I'd watch I
rolled in at 10:07 and thus it was Jeff
Ross and and in chelsea and louis c.k
and Gaffigan benson Sarah Silverman
Craig Robinson those are just the
weekend lineups and you couldn't get
anybody there to buy ticket so I started
doing bringer shows and [ __ ] like that
just so I could get crowds in the comedy
juice he actually brought comedy oh you
did I saw the line out the door of laugh
factor every Wednesday whatever and I
knew glebe and I started talking those
guys I'm like what are you doing so I
brought it over
and it was National Lampoon at the time
yep and we turn over but I mean that was
just like the dream as a comedy fan like
doing that and it was the greatest time
of my life isn't it funny how the comedy
community the comedy fraternity it's
like you get addicted to the life like
that's why you see like on Sunday
Larry David came to the Comedy Store I'm
ready posting a video of it and then
yeah you can't get it out of your bum
it's like so I don't even care if it's
like takes another four or five years
for me to like be a headlining comedian
while I'm doing nothing I don't even
care get Louis black look at look at
Louie there's how many comics yeah hey
way later yeah in their career it's look
at Bert yeah yeah absolutely
Christ sure not yell we've even before
young American tour Christ I did some
fun shows with Chrysler he took me like
some Club in Chicago with a guy only
paid cash and like afterwards you were
like going to some after-party with like
a pitbull and a gang member and I mean a
Chrysler was like awesomely naive but I
was kind of had like a street thing
going I already knew where we were in a
trouble spot but crusher and I had a lot
a lot of fun times can you confirm the
the Chrysler Tracy Morgan story or the
Jay Mohr tells that didn't you know
which I don't know I don't know that
story no I don't know I guess I'm back
and forth oh no it goes back and forth
what is it he influenced him to take his
shirt off some comedy drop there's
always a little drawing always like on
the outside was a story what's real
what's not know you know what's funny
I'm never knock out what I've never had
comedy beef I've never had beef with
another comedian I've never where does
it come from it comes from obviously
stealing material I mean that whole
thing with with but where would comedy
beef come from
jealousy egos people are so sit back and
like the best thing the best thing I
ever heard
not never heard but like one of the best
things I got off that documented would
Dre and Jimmy Iovine did you watch
amazed so I've even basically says when
racehorses race they put blinders on
right here so they can't see what this
guys doing and this guy is doing this
horse is doing and that's how you got to
go about your whole career so like
jealousy to me he's never benefit I've
never had a jealous I've really never
jealous because I don't look you can't
look at what's going on here or here you
gotta be in your lane and crush your
lane I feel like I never had beef yeah I
think you've been like that in your
career and I think it just helps it's
like why even the only beef I've had is
when I'm you know I'm getting
sucker-punched outside of a clutch we
don't need to bring that up but Joe was
like I felt bad for you then 40 minutes
in I did I felt bad for you that we have
you know I mean but listen you know
what's interesting it's a story I've
told before but yeah I got I got beat up
after a show somewhere but um I mean you
were hitting on the guy's girlfriend not
saying you deserved it no no no story
yes I'll be the girl but I mean they go
but for you to even think that that's
what it was you you're so nice China
this is turning this is to keep it good
no cuz what Hat trying not only was I'm
not hitting on Fighting's no the girl no
no I sat next to me in a club in the
club next door and she was rubbing my
arm I just thought to myself life is
better she's on ecstasy problem I got
sucker-punched by a stalker it wasn't
even him oh but she wasn't in the ship
they were in the show though she was in
the shoes and the he was in the net
she was in the show getting googly eye
googly eyed when you were up there and
it kind of started not on your side she
came to me she came to us and said yo
you guys want to go next door for a
drink my friend owns the place or
whatever we went over there I'm sitting
in a booth with the fellas and she's
rubbing my arm and out of nowhere BAM I
just got punched in the face out of
nowhere it turned out he was a pro he
had prior convictions abuse go to jail
or I yeah I put him in jail she wouldn't
come up with the name right away she was
like
her acting was so bad she was like oh my
god what just happened I'm saying you
know the [ __ ] that was and so I got his
name I got his number blah blah blah got
him arrested night I was packed months
later ready to go to trial I was flying
to Miami I was coming out there my [ __ ]
was packed ready to go I get a call from
his lawyer he wants to make a deal he
doesn't want to go he's he's afraid he's
going to jail so I thought to myself
South Florida's wild you never know
there is a chance he wouldn't go to jail
so I wanted to just take his money yeah
so I basically came up with a number
that was just triple what I wanted I
sent it back to his lawyer he accepted
it and every month I got it every week I
got a check from the Department of
Corrections in Florida to garnish his
wages they had to refinance his house
it's like a residuary movie you did but
no that's great by the way high residual
no but that's I deserved it on set it
was a very bad moment but that was young
American yeah but that's it that's a
problem with like comics because what
happens is these girls and fans they
come in and they danger they look up and
if if the comic looks their way it
automatically is oh my god this they're
into me it's it's a thing like there's a
lot of girls like that you know come to
these shows and that are waiting outside
and they're they have false hope and
you're like all right guys yeah it's a
different thing sneaking them out in the
back but I mean no amazing is it I mean
to look up at a person that close to you
that's on X Y & Z TV show that you're
like right there that's what's so great
about stand-up comedy is you're standing
you're sitting 10 20 feet from a name
that's my go-to go comedy clubs no
comedy theaters yeah a comedy club as
owners that can't be the only story
you've seen or heard like you've seen oh
no there's any of those things like
situations like I had one in Oxnard with
with Jon Lovitz he he was in the crowd
somebody like yelled out and he's like
shut up you effing can't
and after the show we can curse we can't
say that yeah you could say every effort
see what I got there was an applause
break good that's home bacon write it
down write comeback 45 minutes in
cocaine it's a break so yeah he calls
him that that's like hard to follow no
go ahead
no what happened I wanted to I did some
bikers we know yeah I mean it was like a
thing like they went over there's a bar
called copper blues which there's one in
Phoenix and cityscape above light and uh
Tito's and Lovitz I guess the guy big
biker did you hear the story oh you know
he's a biker because that's where they
live now a biker dude and basically
waited we bring Jon Lovitz out the guy
goes after him goes try to punch him and
beat him up we had like gravel of its
and it was like a thing because he's
like dude I'm not letting you call my
wife a [ __ ] smart car yeah I did I
mean there's women present I don't mean
just the so there's there's a so there's
a book called I killed I don't know if
you've read the book so it's about the
old school comedians going not even old
school Tim Allen Seinfeld Dahmer errors
in it a bunch of those guys are in the
book and so that book is all about their
Road stories so when I read the book I
realize okay I'm not the only person
this has happened to like Seinfeld
offended a mobster in Jersey he had to
go to a sit-down
you know II mean Tim Allen got like
accosted somewhere before his you know
cocaine charge in jail time you know but
even before that he had gotten like beat
up somewhere like on the road so the one
thing was the biggest we had one of the
biggest brawls ever in comedy history we
don't talk about it can we talk about it
yes no I want to I know we have time
yeah we got time with 14 more minutes we
got 14 minutes all right well there's
gonna be do you really have 14 minutes
yeah we're good we have three no no
we're good I like Mike Mike's running
the light no no this is this is like a
crazy story so we have my gaps at
sold-out show I'd stand up live right
next to operable is over Chico mala
it's it's what I do in cityscape so all
of a sudden Tito's back to
okay go ahead you got my cups so my caps
so there's a couple sitting up front big
fan of course my gaps ticket prices and
cheap they spend a good amount of money
they come out Mike Epps has an entourage
locally because he has local entourage
is everywhere he goes I mean like he
hires some gangsters too pretty no like
no just bros like yeah
hey man I'm friends with my gaps I go
right to gangster yeah I mean pretty
much gangster yeah and all of a sudden
there's Mike Epps is going back and
forth with a guy all of a sudden our
door because we have a door that leads
to the stage one of these gangsters
opens up the door and it's like
basically am i correct like pointing at
the guy going I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
it was heckling I mean it's a typical
comedy comes no just happens no but did
it just start out as a basic heckle yeah
a basic going back that wasn't there you
know like absolute you know like he
didn't give a [ __ ] but these guys did
then all of a sudden they leave they
leave the greenroom they walk around
into the exit into the entrance of the
comedy club where it's half in half out
and it's pointing to the guy going I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up so the guy's a big a
diesel guy tries to get up we're like
look I just take a seat all of a sudden
as the lights are about to go up after
the show got my young sucker punch I'm
not more than that a whole fight breaks
out tables chairs I mean there had to be
30 people fighting like fist fighting
throughout the club
holy [ __ ] so Epps's crew versus the
hecklers crew know everything yet agree
the best part was that I turned my phone
off so was it silent so I didn't get
those text messages at 2:00 and 4:00 and
5:00 in the morning saying hey pick up
there's been a big smile but there that
was such part of this is what's crazy
the the guy and it's so sad
Terrance up getting [ __ ] kicked out of
them I mean they were kicking him to
sleep all the Sun in my bartender that's
a girl all these guy servers they're all
around they're scattering our female
bartender jumps into the fight starts
punching grabbing people to get off this
guy to drag him in missus guy he's just
busted up damn and this I mean like it's
not like this isn't I mean this is
definitely the worst no it's like my
worst like when you spend all that time
and energy to have stuff like that but
because you you hope nowadays there's no
safe environment like for some reason
with comedy clubs - they had they become
less safe because now everything's
captured right everything that happens
within that club whether it's material
or whatever it used to be that safe
place where you could go and as a comic
and you know work it out and so now it's
just it literally like makes you want to
quit but because when something like
that happens I mean it's literally the
worst and then you don't get support of
the people that you're supposed to and
then when you talk to Mike like I you
know I've known Mike forever and I'm
talking to his road manager and they're
like we don't know those guys and we're
like they were inside your greenroom you
were hanging out with them like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
and then on top of it you have real fans
that paid great money to see Mike and
Gaea blame Mike what do you blame his
entourage my Mike didn't turn around and
go go get home no you know so it's like
100% either way it solves a lot of
things that probably happened that you
know you look back it's like anything
you look back you're like how do you
prevent it but it's those things in
comedy it's like you know it's it's it's
those those nights and people coming out
so but [ __ ] like that was weathertech
line I mean you saw that there was that
video of the guy it's that famous video
where the guy he's a guitar comic and
somebody is running up at the stage and
he takes the guitar and hits him over
the head you ever seen that video no I
didn't see that that's not comedy it's
like it's the grand irony is that what
you're alone on a stage you're
unprotected basically and you're just
trying to make people laugh expose
closely expose and do you think social
media has part that because nowadays
they're on Twitter or whatever and
they're commenting everywhere so do you
think nowadays that actually it's it's
it's heard it in the sense of because
when you're heckling whatever they feel
like that they can actually respond to
your material because they're doing it
online and everywhere else I think there
might be a tiny bit more of like calling
response type [ __ ] going on where the
crowd doesn't get that you can't talk
back that you shouldn't be doing it
remember I don't I don't think it's
changed drastically when you're when
you're
adding alcohol to anything people want
to be the center of attention a lot of
people like to feel like they want to be
part of the show and then what happens
is is when the comic engages when
they're trying it like there's some
comics that really know how to handle I
mean like Bobby slain knows how to shut
someone no doubt wrote Roberge then
there's comics just don't know how to
navigate they're young and they're
they're like they're kind of going back
and forth and and they don't know how to
engage enough to where it's like all
right I want you to have a good time but
you really need to shut the [ __ ] off
like at leas it takes years by the way
to develop that skill
do you know putting of handling it's so
crazy it doesn't happen goes on our side
to like we hire these door guys and
we're trying to explain to them how to
keep the room quiet and how to engage a
customer that's there to have a good
time and of course the customer the
first thing they do is I was only a lot
of thing which I did like a Todd glass
thing he did like a bit about that but
my voice and and he would go well you're
not kicked out because you were just
laughing you know what the worst part is
the clubs get blamed for all of it
whether it's like oh this is out of your
control and you know it's like when a
comics doing three hours on the Early
Show and it's a hundred degrees outside
in Phoenix and you got 300 people
waiting in line you know they blame the
club and there's only so much you can do
because look you want to make sure that
they have the best experience possible
because it hurts everybody right so if
you're going in there and you're
hilarious whatever and there have a bad
time or they're waiting too much in line
you're already like running uphill and
so there's just so many moving parts
that come into play to that of a great
show where we're protecting the artists
too and protecting the show to make sure
that it is is a good time but company
like owning comedy clubs again there's
there's some really incredible
incredible things and then there's
things that you know that we try to
prevent and you know we're trying to
make the best experience possible and we
understand that in certain markets
there's hot weather and certain markets
there's cold weather and it's it's
really hard to put in 300 people in and
300 people out and
making sure that everyone feels like
what they're feeling is the most
important it's like that it's like
everyday everyday life and that's what
we do we deal with thousands of
personalities every day do you prep your
staff as like like I don't know I don't
like on an approachable like you give
them like how to approach the come Adam
friendly first always always friendly
and then you know on the second approach
you know like you teach them how to
throw somebody out if they have to get
through it like you tell them be cool at
first cuz they're here for fun like you
said unfortunately when everybody else
is done yeah but unfortunately it's only
very important between that it works out
great
you always have that either drunk guy
that I didn't do anything wrong and he's
causing a scene and then everyone's
looking to the right and then you know
for a comedian again I'm not a comedian
but about timing and you know ruining
that show and you know you have these
headliners that just don't want to deal
with it and that's why they don't want
to work comedy clubs because there's so
many comedy clubs out there right now
you know that don't protect the talent
yeah and that's why I think we pride
ourselves Maddy and I in the clubs that
we own and operate that we're always
concentrating on talent is king
everything is about the talent what is
phase one you guys have been like that
you guys run the tightest ship of any
comedy chain I think I've ever seen and
I've been including theaters I mean I've
been everywhere now if Sebastian was
sagging rogue everywhere
you guys do run it's because you love
the games it's good I will know you have
you heard of the and we've done it twice
well we did it once here with Michael
che but and when I went to go see
Chappelle and went to see Rock they're
using yonder it's called yonder where
you put your cell phone in a pouch I've
heard of it I haven't seen it you know
we were thinking about doing that at the
club because that's another problem is
that you know it's very hard I'm only
taking a photo and you know I paid $30
ticket or I paid terrible distracting to
Sara so you know guys like rock and guys
like you know Chappell granted they're
protecting their material especially
when they have a special coming out yeah
but I think it's great just for the fact
that
the distraction of it its execution
that's a tough it's really tough I think
it's actually more I think it's a more
it's more beneficial for distraction
than it is material like what does
someone gonna like I mean you're
everyone's gonna catch Chris's material
or chappelle's with you at some point
you know I mean like I'm really worried
that someone's gonna get a three-minute
bit out there and it's gonna like take
away from ticket sales I think it's a
great thing for distraction how do you
end it I have no I know it's it's tough
to execute walking nightmares it's a
magnet in a pouch and then you think
about this like you know I don't have
any kids but Maddy has two and if all of
a sudden his babysitter tries to reach
out it's like but you know what 25 years
ago for the babysitter head now look
alright no it's cool though they work
they don't have to take days off kept
looking at your phone and touching it it
was a really killer experience to not
even be able to touch it and you really
like I you talk to people yeah and liked
it was a it was for Chappelle rocked it
it too and you're just so focused on the
experience that the right it's that
distraction and when you're tunnel
vision would go back to the blinder so
it was cool it was a good it was I don't
want to date myself but we even when I
started people are even smoking cigs
inside the showroom and I had these
smokeeaters
that all that you hear can you make a
cricket noise I kind of crackle II and
you would hear it and Joel grew up
smoking on airplanes yeah in the 60s I
mean there's a couple people in this
room I'm sure had that as well no I mean
you were like just the first row above
smoking and my favorite my favorite was
when they would take their sick and put
it out on a banquette and then you would
have a big burn all that was my favorite
she always loved Mad Men was based on
Joel yeah it's it was love smoking
things in Chicago at the zany's where
that Club there there's no like smoking
cigs watching comedy that's a great save
how many chicken fingers you should do
one night only smoking cigs eaten
chicken fan you can just smoke cigs and
watch comedy cigs and smoke every Sunday
seeking speaking of smoking drinking
r.i.p Ralphie may my homeboy listen I'm
a chemo and
sad notifier listen to me Ralphy was the
best bro every time I would see Ralphy
to the literally like weeks ago he was
like Mike Young I got the jump rope with
me [ __ ] I'm bringing it back I'm
gonna start boxing I'm jump the rope I'm
clearing out the lungs he would know me
man for some reason I would always have
him again right now I would always be
wearing a blue shirt so all of a sudden
I'd be listening to radio are we
wrapping it up like this so Ralphie
story and he would all I don't know what
it in my favorite colors blue but all of
a sudden I'd be checking checking in
listening to Monterey do and all of a
sudden he would just be going on about
Joel and his blue shirt and I'm
listening to him on the radio and as
open we're opening up the doors you're
like oh you're Joe blue and yes Ralphie
may rest in peace he was an amazing
comic and amazing man and helped a ton
of young comics and he was the perfect
headliner and the perfect comic to help
build comedy yeah and that's what that's
what sucks that we keep losing these
incredible guys like John Pinette and
yeah you know right and the Ralphie maze
of the world and the Richard jenny's
it's it just blows yeah but he sucks
such as life lessons learned I learned a
ton from Ralphie by the way I mean he
was like he taught me disciplined in
writing actually 15 years ago he's like
Mike young look at the paper every day
every day look at the back of the paper
go to that little section of USA Today
where every city every state has it has
a news story just write three jokes out
of different states and then what are
you talking about Ralphie would do is he
would do all the different states all in
one show so the show ended four went for
three hours
yeah he covered all the cities I was
like China did the thing but this I
would really love and I don't want to
make it about Matt komen but I would
really love for Matt to tell you the
homeless man's story just because we're
downtown cityscape is it a good one to
wrap up on no it's really a good wrap it
just
you start off with where are you which
food shop I go to 7-eleven I was single
like I would go if they had closed I
would about closed at 7-eleven cuz it's
like literally was they had everything
it was your Costco
yeah it was my Costco at the time when I
go and it was on my way home and I had a
homeless guy do you ever have a homeless
guy this is a friend you know what I
mean you always like take care of him
he's always at the same spot you know
I'm there on Friday night yeah yeah I
got a guy care of him you know he always
oh man he's like thank God it's Friday
and I'm like seriously like I'm like and
then what time I'm gonna nobody get the
whole thing like it I got strata didn't
do anything I mean everyone listening
like this you trying to give me his
first and best bit
no just he's not telling it was great I
continued no no continue just get him
some milk yeah he offers in nine hundred
degree weather when it's surreal for any
homeless man I'm dumping milk out the
window and I hear the little tap on the
on the window it was like he wanted a
very specific kind of milk yeah that's
amazing it's amazing like he knows what
he wants he had a tough week he might
have been lactose intolerant so to me I
thought it was great I miss him
great great great story shout out if
he's here this weekend come on we're
down here comedy boom all right we're
wrapping up Joel bash cough Matt Coleman
Michael Rapaport by the way I feel like
Michael Rapaport I ghost wrote his book
did I tell you that yes we rap tonight I
wanna say do you like the whole thing
again what we do I mean I got we got a
book coming out it came out yesterday
it's called this this book has balls
it's Rappaport's book I was the
ghostwriter it just came out help he's
gonna be straight you know I don't know
I actually just prize NDA I actually can
we know we rewind I truly don't know the
rules ago sure I took the cash line and
the backend money you got back in a
ghost right yeah goes yeah but we were
young Americans he 2018 let's do this
for the record he boom he did a ton of
writing things along ready I just
cleaned it up Mike Young stories that
need to be told fellas thank you thank
you thank you
automated of live this is the first
first festival first podcast of the
festival and yo young American comedy
thank you so much Joe off the back row
you're gonna hear from me every week man
nobody will even hear this to even know
that we're doing it you better really
out there all things comedy piece Jack
[Applause]
good jump